[Music]
I like nuts the dumpling Don you know
quantized into 1/16 bread for a bar one
particular piece of hardware that we
took a liking to that I use with my wife
says thing called Amana me
[Music]
it comes in a box no manual amount of
software I know right
no nothing just that your table and then
there's a farm because here and then
they're like you have to download the
FTDI driver from this right that's all
install your cereal obligation this is
like by the time I tell you about it all
you just got it doing something you like
right all right what am I gonna do sleep
there was a bit of a buzz around it but
the problem we found with the mommy is
that you had to run max/msp in the
background and then you had to run your
live application and you only sent over
a mini note and then the problem with
Ableton Live is that it didn't accept
OSC which is the communication for the
call this thing uses so it was just like
a pile of hack nests so we've basically
taken the max I must be out of the
equation and then came in like a kind of
step sequencer based application that
connected this device without any
third-party applications where we can
use that kind of MIDI information or all
IC information to trigger loops and
joining hits
simply stated your file mixes are to the
point where like mastering people don't
really need to even mess with it
everyone's got like a kind of
methodology for making like a bus for
say just your drums on that channel
because you want only certain things to
to compress certain things so I got all
the bass only one that get drugged it
present that bass or nothing else in
this hi-hat go and you know so she looks
a lot of fussing but so you develop
these kind of systems or like or bus
routines that you go through coming up
to that is like you know culmination of
ten years worth of Jessica and I are
certain it's a hardware and software
encase techniques and stuff like that
[Music]
[Applause]